- 'CAUSE I'M CHANGING
THE PLAN.
IT'S GONNA BE MTV TRUE LIFE:
I'M INTO OLD PEOPLE.
I DON'T CARE.
- WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
CHECK OUT THIS OLD BRAJ.
[blues music]
- ♪ ON A BIG OL'
SHADY OAK TREE ♪
- [laughing]
OH, MAN. THIS DUDE IS SICK!
I'M TALKING, LIKE,
TERMINALLY CHILL.
- [singing]
- HE IS CHILL.
I'M JUST GONNA NEED
A FRESHER ANGLE
THAN SOME AGED ROCKER.
I MEAN, W.W.K.L.D.?
WHAT WOULD KURT LODER DO?
- ♪ SAID I WAS BORN
- OLD PEOPLE HAVE BEEN AROUND
SINCE THE DAWN OF TIME.
THEY HAVE STORIES AND MESSAGES.
HERE'S ONE NOW.
HEY, MA'AM, CAN I ASK YOU
A FEW QUES--
WE'LL FIND A BETTER ONE
THAN THAT.
HEY, NICE SHOT.
- I KNOW.
- IS IT OKAY IF I ASK YOU
A COUPLE QUESTIONS?
- QUESTIONS?
- JUST QUESTIONS
ABOUT YOUR LIFE.
YOU KNOW, I FEEL LIKE PEOPLE
OF YOUR GENERATION
HAVE SUCH WISDOM
THAT YOU CAN SHARE.
WHY DON'T YOU TELL ME
ABOUT WHAT YOU DID
BEFORE YOU LIVED HERE?
- I TRAVELED TO THE WORLD'S
BEST CITIES,
AND IN EXCHANGE,
I MARRIED A RICH MAN
I DIDN'T LOVE.
- YEAH.
- BUT ENOUGH ABOUT ME.
SHOOT.
- I-I DON'T KNOW HOW TO PLAY.
MY DAD NEVER LET ME IN THE
BILLIARDS ROOM GROWING UP, SO--
- OH, THAT'S HEARTBREAKING.
MAYBE I CAN HELP YOU.
- OW.
ALL RIGHT, I'LL START LOW?
- NOW, BEFORE YOU SHOOT...
[whispers]
CLOSE YOUR EYES,
AND PUT IT IN.
- IS EVERYTHING OKAY
IN HERE?
- IT'S FINE, MARK.
JUST FINE.
WHY DON'T WE GO SOMEWHERE
WHERE WE CAN BE
A LITTLE MORE PRIVATE?
- ALL RIGHT.